what exactly is the purpose of the
protest
uh two things to end the mandates on
vaccinations because
and by the way i'm vaccinated i'm fully
vaccinated and i usually get the flu
vaccine every year so when we're doing
the anti-vaxx thing sorry that's not us
uh so to end the vaccine mandates and
allow people the freedom of choice
whether we agree or disagree with that
choice it's their freedom of choice
and to end the um
the it's called the arrive can it's a
covid passport app
similar to what the pair the provinces
have rolled out which they're now uh
rolling back
and this app goes on your phone and
while it tracks you it has your coveted
health status on your phone
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is an emergency episode it's an
interview with one of the leaders of the
canadian trucker convoy i tried to ask
neutral questions that every canadian
might be interested in and people
outside of canada for that matter it was
recorded today i hope this helped
clarify the situation in canada for
people
a quick word from the sponsor of this
episode
dad and i are on tour and nordvpn is a
lifesaver with the state of the world at
the moment you can't be too careful
about your data
nordvpn is the fastest vpn in the world
it keeps your data safe and anonymous
and nobody gets to tell you what you can
or can't watch
i can't recommend them enough
they have an exclusive
offer for my listeners grab your
exclusive nord vpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp like the michaela peterson podcast
tmpp or use the code tmpp to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus one
additional month for free plus a bonus
gift it's completely risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee enjoy
this episode
[Music]
hey welcome to my podcast
well thank you
thank you for having me
i really wanted to talk to you to get
you on to address a whole bunch of
questions that i think
canadians and people across the world
who are watching what's going on in
ottawa with the trucker protest
i'm hoping to
have you address a whole bunch of those
questions so i want to get through as
many of these as you have time for sure
of course
so first off
who are you
i'm just some guy who owns a truck my
name is benjamin dictor i am i guess the
spokesperson one of the board members of
the freedom convoy
and i was brought in i guess 24 hours
after uh they just decided to go with
this chris and bridget and tamara in
alberta
uh tamara's been a friend of mine for
many years and uh she caught she did a
she they decided they're gonna do a
convoy
uh they're fed up there if you've been
to alberta recently you know rural
alberta now looks like a third world
country and has
for several years now
and they've all had their lives and
their businesses crushed
and they decided this has got to end we
have and they were all about many of
them were about to lose their
uh their jobs because i know at least
one of them
couldn't actually get the covet vaccine
because of some cardiovascular problem
it's none of my business i don't ask
and uh you know she's gonna lose
everything
so they decided we have to do something
and make a statement let's go to ottawa
we'll have a convoy let's do a gofundme
maybe we'll get you know 20 grand which
is will cover some of the gas
and
let's go and see what happens
and 24 hours later uh tamara called me
and said
you won't believe this we started this
our gofundme is at i think it was a
hundred hundred fifty thousand dollars
at that point
and she said uh do you mind coming on
board and helping with messaging and you
know helping organize this as much as
you can from your end
and i said yeah for for you anything no
problem and so we started and it just
grew organically from there
okay so
you said it started
partly because
this lady couldn't get vaccinated
because of health conditions and she was
at risk of losing or she was going to
lose her job because of it so what
exactly is the purpose of the protest
uh two things to end the mandates on
vaccinations because
and by the way i'm vaccinated i'm fully
vaccinated and i usually get the flu
vaccine every year so when we're doing
the anti-vax thing sorry that's not us
uh so to end the vaccine mandates and
allow people the freedom of choice
whether we agree or disagree with that
choice it's their freedom of choice
and to end the uh
the it's called the arrive can it's a
covid passport app
similar to what the pair the provinces
have rolled out which they're now
rolling back
and this app goes on your phone and well
it tracks you it has your coveted health
status on your phone
and you know i explained this on tucker
carlson and a couple of other shows that
i the first time i ever had to use it
was a week before all of this started
i was crossing the border from new york
into into ontario
and i went to hold my phone up to the
border agent with my qr code and i said
here you go i don't know what to do but
do what you need
and he said to me no no i don't need to
see it uh and this wouldn't mean you'll
need to see it he said well when your
phone gets within a certain radius
of our booth uh your phone just pops up
on my screen and all your information is
there already
so i i could see you before you even
came up to the booth
and it occurred to me at that point you
know
everybody is so
concerned you many of our politicians
posture the concern of data tracking
from uh big tech firms like facebook and
twitter and whatnot but at least with
those platforms we can opt out but with
the government we can't opt out and
what's going to be what's the next step
are they going to start rolling that out
to all government uh buildings
across the country like i don't know
maybe that's hyperbolic to think maybe
that's just too dystopian but it's
clearly a possibility at this point
maybe every police cruiser will have a
receiver that could monitor each you
know covet app and phone in its vicinity
maybe it's just a bit of a slippery
slope argument but
we keep sliding down this slope
and nothing seems to be changing so i
think there's a cause for concern maybe
i'm crazy
i don't think you're crazy
i don't think
you're welcome uh okay so let's i have a
whole bunch more questions for you but i
figure i might as well hit this at the
beginning
what do you guys need to see from the
government in order to
stop protesting
well i mean ultimately we need to see
mandates removed and the passport app
dropped that's it it's pretty simple and
it's not like we are asking for
constitutional reforms or we're asking
for reparations or asking for
any dramatic change
to our country we just want things to be
restored to way they are and we want the
government to get out of our phone like
it's pretty simple you know
but we haven't even had anybody from the
government
uh sit down and meet with us which is
interesting you know justin trudeau can
meet with joshua boyle he can meet with
omar khadr but he can't meet with
his working class
transportation infrastructure who have
what i think are reasonable grievances
right and again it's not about vaccines
people can get vaccinated people can
quarantine at home as they please that's
fine
but it should be allowed up to the
individual to choose how they want to
live their lives
okay so what does it look like on the
ground in ottawa like what kind of
people are over there how many people
um how many i have no idea and it
changes day to day so on the weekends is
when things really uh peak up
there seems to be a lot of people that
are coming from you know
other jurisdictions whether it's quebec
get a lot of people coming from quebec
southern ontario
and now people from coming from vermont
and new york state and new hampshire uh
coming to essentially the biggest block
party in canada's history which we call
trudeau's truck stop uh it's an amazing
vibe uh you know some of my guys came
back it was the last night the night
before they came back to the hotel
because i'm a little bit incapacitated
so i can only go to you know a number of
meetings that in certain areas
and i said to them okay you guys hungry
i'll order dinner because there's five
or six of them here they're like oh no
we're stuffed like what do you mean like
everybody's barbecuing and throwing food
in our face
so you walk around downtown ottawa every
trucker every other you know group has a
little barbecue set up they have flags
they're having taking pictures with
people
they're trying to spread this message of
we're peaceful and loving there's music
going on like if there were bouncy
castles until i think a couple days ago
when justin trudeau thought the bouncy
castles were a threat
but the vibe has been amazing it's like
it's what i would imagine
without let's say the recreational drugs
it's what i imagine woodstock would have
been like that sort of feel to it or
wembley like those sorts of
you know big hearty atmospheres that's
what it's like in uh in downtown ottawa
it's amazing and on top of that you know
they talk about oh the blockade
what blockade
yeah there's a lot of trucks parked
illegally but we have an ops team that
you know have experienced ex-military
ex-police
that have established emergency routes
for emergency vehicles traffic is
flowing around the city slower there's
no question but traffic is still flowing
we're trying to
minimize the disruption to people in the
city
and the local businesses who have stayed
open and violated the mayor's order to
close by the way so the mayor has issued
an order that any business that opens
will be issued a ticket for however much
money it is i don't know
but like the shawarma shop like that
we've been going to just about every day
they said we have we are so thankful we
have never been so busy in three years
thank you everybody for what you're
doing and all the businesses that have
been staying open have been prospering
okay one of the criticisms i've read
about you guys in the media is that this
is a an alt-right
thing that's going on and a whole bunch
of the people who've gone to canada
aren't even canadian
and so you mentioned that there are
people who are coming in from vermont in
other areas so how do you feel about
that
well what happened to peace unity and
love what happened to open borders what
happened to we're all one world we're a
post national state it's amazing how
they flip from that ideology to we need
hard borders now and canadians
are completely different than americans
um the americans that are coming are
definitely a minority here uh i would i
would guess the largest contingency
as separate from the truckers who have
come from uh the prairies are people
from quebec
and that's been most amazing seeing
people from quebec
hanging out with the people they're
supposed to not like from alberta
becoming friends talking to each other
through google translate
and
there's a couple of pictures i took i
took with a couple of guys one guy was
from alberta one guy was from quebec and
they're both holding signs i had to take
a picture one said freedom one said
liberte
they were hanging out all day together
standing beside each other and just
shaking everybody's hands and hugging
everybody and whatever
and that's been the vibe the whole time
and you know i told this story a few
times
of one of my friends who was here
helping with my leg
after i broke it which was fun
she went to the tim hortons to grab
coffee in the morning and she said you
won't believe this
i just went to tim hortons and there's
these two guys and she's quite astute
there's these two guys in lying
they clearly are friends they didn't
just meet each other and they're talking
and they're laughing they're pointing
and all this sort of stuff
and they're dressed as truckers so we
assume they are she says but they're
talking to each other through google
translate because one is one was french
and one i think she said was from
saskatchewan or alberta so they couldn't
communicate directly but they formed a
friendship and some sort of bond and
they're starting to try to learn a
little bit of french and a little bit of
english and
it's just lovely it's it's the it's the
first
real unity i've seen in canada i mean
you know we've all grown up with this
baggage of all the separatists here and
the western separatists and nobody likes
each other and nothing could be further
from the truth when government and the
media get out of the way
the people unify and they learn they
learn to love each other and respect
each other's differences and that's what
we've seen all week
okay interesting well that's good to
hear um what about all this news about
um i mean you see you get certain
pictures from the media and at the very
beginning there was some sort of statue
story it was like oh these people are
desecrating statues
i call it hoax hate okay okay so let's
get into that a little bit what was that
about
uh well there were a few of them first
there was the um
the nazi flag that we're alt-right we're
all nazis and whatever
uh i'd hate to tell mr trudeau
i'm jewish
and some of us still have families in
mass graves in europe so that smears not
going to work
tamara is a metis so she's from the
native community
so
we're the racist but mr blackface he's
the virtuous one it's
clown world it's ridiculous right
yeah so somebody um and this happens a
lot in protests where
people you know age and provocateurs or
whatever you want to call it they'll
stage different things right and they're
so in this particular case i mean nobody
saw this until it was all over all over
the web somebody uh unraveled a swastika
flag a nazi flag
and it was nowhere near any of like any
of the protests or any of the trucks or
whatever
it was some back corner of some park and
there just happened to be somebody with
a ten thousand dollar cam
a cannon camera
perfectly lined up for the shot you know
this was the money shot
so i don't imagine
putting the sign mandate freedom
uh on terry fox
would have been terribly offensive to uh
the man who
required those basic freedoms to run
across the country which we can't do
right now right without being harassed
by the government
so that was the second hoax hate
then there was the uh war memorial hoax
hate which was it started and you can
tell it's a hoax when they keep changing
the reason
so first it was a truck parked on the
war memorial
no no truck parked on the war memorial a
truck parked in the spot adjacent to the
war memorial that the cbc usually parks
in at uh memorial day events so perhaps
they were upset one of our trucks took
their parking spot i would be upset too
right
um then
the 24 hours or 48 hours later it became
somebody desecrated the uh tomb of the
unknown soldier have no idea how it was
just the word desecrated no specificity
whatsoever
and then 24 hours after that it became
somebody urinated on the tomb of the
unknown soldier or the war memorial
somebody took a picture it was a little
bit of a warmer day that day
of uh a snow bank that had water melting
on the bottom took a picture and that
apparently was urine i guess they
haven't realized that you know uh snow
melts at zero degrees but okay fine
so
and what was interesting about that is
because you know they they're so
disconnected the uh i call them i don't
call them the global elites i call them
the global scavenger class
they're so disconnected from regular
people
they miscalculate one very basic
phenomenon we all know
that most people or so many people in
trucking are either veterans themselves
or come from veteran families
so just the fact that that narrative was
out there upset them hugely to the point
that a bunch of them got together
with some veteran truckers they grab
they got their shovels and equipment and
stuff they shoveled all the snow around
the war memorial
cleaned it up better than the city has
ever done made sure there was no garbage
or any that sort of stuff
they went and got bouquets of flowers
and they took a beautiful picture of it
somewhere it's somewhere on the internet
they lined the tomb of the unknown
soldier with flowers and then they they
assigned a team that would rotate shifts
24 7 to ensure
nobody would be desecrating the war
memorial or the tomb the unknown soldier
so that's the reality of what happened
what went on
okay yes that's definitely different
than what
you're hearing about mainstream media
things are pretty crazy
let's call them legacy media they're not
mainstream their fringe media is what
they are okay
legacy media that's definitely more
accurate yeah
okay so
um
let's see has there been any violence
uh not that i've seen i mean maybe the
kids playing on the bouncy castles are
considered violence because you know we
live in a world where words are violence
so
who knows what uh the fake news media
defines violence but no no cops have
been injured no people have been injured
there's not been any scrum i mean
again these people so many of these
people come from veteran families they
respect the government they're not here
to overthrow the government because they
spend so much of their lives serving the
government
so it's a completely different you know
dynamic than perhaps
you know the uh the leftist militias
that protest where they're
anti-government that's not us so no we
haven't seen any of it and also people
are cognizant of
being baited by uh you know leftist
activists into you know a january six
like incident and whatever and
when nobody is taking debate we
understand
that uh this that's not what this is
about this is about a peaceful
loving protest and in many ways
especially people have been coming
from other jurisdictions it's been you
know a source of inspiration for younger
people to see how our process works
and how people can come together and
unify and want to talk to the government
and that the government works for us
not the other way around which is seems
to be the mindset of some people in our
political class
okay so
um i'd like a bit of a timeline i know
that this is what i think happened
from what i've been reading but you can
tell me what actually happened but i
believed i believed government officials
tried to hire tow trucks to come
take out the trucks and and they just
said no i thought that there's been an
issue with police
arresting people so can you give me a
bit of background uh information on the
tow trucks police involvement and how
people are trying to get rid of the
protesters and how that hasn't been
working
okay so with the total we'll start with
the policing and the arresting
um from what i understand a handful of
people were arrested
earlier in the week
sorry earlier last week and it was an
intimidation tactic right
charge them with you give them a ticket
for mischief so let's drive him down to
the station give him a ticket for 150
and that's kind of it from what i
understand it hasn't been anything more
than that
i'm not sure
and on police on the police level we've
had a we've actually had a great
relationship with
the police on the ground
many of us not only do we have people
from military families but many of us
come from
police families like i have family and
policing as well so we kind of
understand
that the ground level police officers
are in a difficult position
and we have a common problem and
phenomenon in canada where the upper
levels of policing the chiefs and deputy
chiefs sometimes are often very
politicized they're more
politicians than they are police
officers because they're appointed by
these ridiculous police services boards
by people who are in political parties
so that that's that's something that has
to end and be fixed in our country
that's another issue
but uh so the relationship with police
has been great many of them have
you know there was a time when
last week they were taking the uh
they're seizing gas cans for people
and they thought that would anger us and
most of us maybe i have a dark sense of
humor
i was on the floor laughing i thought
if you want an epic pr disaster for
police
that's the way to do it take fuel from
people who just want to keep themselves
warm
and then the next day they threatened oh
we're going to raid the you know we're
going to raid all the the trucks and
what did they end up doing they found
some guys that were having bonfires to
keep themselves warm so they went and
seized their cord of wood and i thought
yeah stupid is gonna double down on
stupid no matter what and i was
predicting a little before then
that i i told people in a couple of
speeches i gave i said
the chief of police of ottawa i promise
you is going to take early retirement
and guess what he just announced 45
minutes ago that he has resigned his
position
because he too is being put in a
position and being politicized
by his local city council
who are
very rabid aggressive leftists that
would have done
well during the bolshevik era like some
of the rhetoric coming from them
is not becoming of anybody who holds
office in a liberal democracy it's quite
concerning
but even he i think it was too much for
even him and last week we had a senior
there was a senior uh staff sergeant
which if you're pulling if you're in
policing you know that's a significant
position
a senior staff sergeant also resigned
his position last week
wow
yeah okay
so what happened with the tow trucks
so with the tow trucks or you apologize
for that uh it's so funny
so many things happen
um the federal government and the city
government were calling just every tow
truck company that they could
even down to
tow truck companies in
a new york state
and we
had that tow truck company from new york
state reach out to us saying yeah i
guess you called us for an order they
said they need a massive
you know convoy of tow trucks to come
for ottawa and
they uh he said to us but don't worry
we like all the other tow truck
truck companies inform them that we all
have coven so we can't come
and then one tow truck company came from
i think it was quebec i might be wrong
they showed up with a small fleet of tow
trucks and they said yeah sure we'll
come we'll we'll show up they came and
they joined the protest it was
hysterical
because remember
tow truck drivers truck drivers these
are people who work through the night
they see emergencies on the road they
see accidents they sometimes help people
in need who are stranded so there's a
little bit of a brotherhood that goes on
behind them
and that that bond seems to be much
stronger than some government
bureaucratic demands go figure
okay so
what do you think is gonna happen like
what happened recently with trudeau
it's interesting when he gave that press
conference uh i was watching that and i
thought like theo fury uh
correctly uh i think i agree with his
assessment on twitter
he said well trudeau has played his
final card
we'll see what happens next and when i
watched that press conference he said
something funny
saying you know this does not bring in
the military and i thought yeah because
you tried last week and the military
told you to take a hike and we know that
because we have people in the military
so trudeau hasn't learned this axiom a
general without an army is a fool and
that's the position he's in so now he's
you know got all hysterical and even
people
who are on you know the left side of the
political spectrum but who you know
embraced the values of freedom and i
think the canadian liberties association
for example even the toronto star today
even they have said okay this is way
way overboard so he's made himself look
like a fool to his own people
and what are we gonna do we're just
gonna wait
wow so can you can you explain to any of
the people watching who don't know what
happened like what exactly happened what
are the emergency measure acts a bit of
background information there
um it's best to talk to a constitutional
lawyer about it but they started this on
the
uh the city level they just declared a
state of emergency last last week
because
you know a bunch of trucks are illegally
parked
oh my god
it was so funny
and then doug ford uh you know mr
conservative mr you know for the people
i think nuked his own political career
as well
by trying to seize all our funds and
declaring a provincial state of
emergency
okay nothing changed because well
there's a bunch of trucks parked
illegally
okay
and now they're going to try on the
federal level
okay what are they going to do can't
call in the military like he said he
doesn't this doesn't mean they will
and i don't think there's any appetite
from people in the military
to go seize
uh to go arrest uh
truckers people that they may know from
their communities who are just parked
illegally and having a peaceful protest
and have gone out of their way
to
to demonstrate that it's peaceful it's
about unity it's about love
and respect for one another
and we're just going to sit here and
wait so i don't know what's trudeau
going to do next we're going to get the
air force to do a flyover i mean that'd
be cool i love planes so i'd love to see
that
but
what's that going to accomplish i don't
know okay what happened with it so then
this is another thing so many things
have happened this is a very strange
situation but
but well it's a strange situation what
happened to all the donations
uh well we're just gonna have to
litigate it so um
the gofundme donations which was
you know the fake news media was first
reporting that it was frozen which it
wasn't you know the first day they're
saying
all the donations were frozen and i
thought
don't you have eyes you can see the
progress bar of the donations go up
that's not frozen
that's just gofundme's regular procedure
of you know filtering for any new
campaign they do it to ensure it's
abiding by aml regulations and
international banking regulations and
they have to do their due diligence and
okay that's fine we understood that
right and again when we set up gofundme
everybody's like why did you go to
gofundme because we just thought we'd
get like 20 grand for gas like we didn't
realize that people would start using
this as a statement a political
statement to show their displeasure with
a political class which is what it's
become
so they eventually released uh you know
one point something million to us which
i'll get back to that in a second and
then they said we're just going to keep
the rest and give it to whatever charity
we want
so then in came uh florida man ron
desantis and the attorney general of
florida ted cruz a bunch of other people
saying
uh yeah this is criminal fraud and this
warrants an investigation by the u.s
government
and then all of a sudden gofundme is
like no no no we're gonna give it back
it was so funny
oh wow yeah so go fund me pathetic
so then they said okay we're going to
refund everything lots of people have
gotten their refunds not everybody has
lots of people still have not and maybe
there's just a bottleneck on their end
so
then go
then uh reached out to us and we had
some people working with cons get sengo
they spoke to jacob the ceo and he was
great he said we'll do everything in our
power to help rebuild it and
as soon as they launched the freedom
convoy campaign on gifts and go
they got
5 million ddos attacks per hour
so somebody is very motivated and has
many bots that were attacking that
website
and they were overwhelmed
by the amount of by the number of
donations that were coming into the
platform so they just you know smaller
company they didn't have the
infrastructure of gofundme i couldn't
even get on for seven hours just to see
it i wanted to you know look at the
messaging and stuff
it took me seven hours before the web
page would even pop up
and it already achieved one point in the
first 12 hours
1.5 million dollars in donations
and somebody told me we hit 4.5 million
in like the first 24 or 36 hours
something like that but i couldn't tell
because it would the website was so
spotty right
so it got up to
8.5 million dollars
and then doug ford remember man of the
working class right
yeah
he's going to go to court and try to
block this funding for all these
truckers who need to get fuel some of
them are having repair issues and all
that sort of stuff
and doug ford was going to step on the
throat of the working man
and have the government seize
any funds that came in from give send go
so give sengo then said okay we're going
to stop any transfers they didn't have
they didn't transfer anything yet
we'll hold on to it while you guys go to
court and litigate it with uh with the
ontario government which is the process
right now
so then the bitcoin community came out
because i have been a secret bitcoiner
for many many years
and they reached out they started uh a
drive trying to raise bitcoin for the
truckers
and that got up to
1.1 or 1.2 million dollars
in a wallet somewhere to go to the to
the truckers
and that was primarily for legal funds
is what they want they want us to get
aggressive
with the media and the government that's
been attacking us so and that's going to
happen it's just a matter of time
so now christopher friedland decided you
know
you know it's the that philosophy they
have everything i don't like is hitler
well everything i don't like is illegal
right so now bitcoin is illegal
everything's illegal now like that's not
how our legal system works
and unfortunately they're probably going
to find that out the hard way so right
now we're just sitting back and waiting
okay
let me see
what other questions do i have here for
you i think that covered most of it
um
how how long do you like
what happens okay so here's one what
happens if trudeau invokes the emergency
measures act ontario doug ford has
already said um he's okay with that he
thinks it's reasonable right so what
happens if that comes into play are you
guys concerned on the ground that people
are going to start getting arrested or
bank accounts frozen
uh he's already invoked it remember he
did that last night that's what the
press conference was
i thought that okay then i have a
question there and i don't know anything
about this so feel free to explain but i
thought that once you like i thought
that that was a suggestion and then
premieres of each province have to agree
or is that done from what i understand
it's got to go to parliament they got to
vote on it yeah right and that hasn't
happened yet right uh no i don't believe
so maybe that's what's happening today
um i mean you can show you can see how
concerned i am
yeah yeah i i can yeah okay at some
point they're going to learn
the people run the government
they work for us not the other way
around and it might be a hard lesson for
them to learn i mean i'm having people
now suggest to me
that justin trudeau might have just laid
the path for the end of his political
career and the government to fall
and the justification was look at this
it's from a political insider and
friends with he said look at it this way
jack meets singh
keeps alienating himself and the ndp
from the seek community which we have so
many seek truck drivers here like
they've been a big part of the people
who've been feeding people like they're
amazing they're wonderful
um
so he's now been alienating himself even
though the you know the most hardened of
ndp people
understand the importance of protesting
because that's what they do right like
that's that's supposed to be the party
for it right that's right that's right
yeah so if jack made singh is pulled by
his own party and we know he's uh he's
not all that popular right now
well then trudeau is not going to have
the support for the for a minority
government then the government falls and
i guess we go to an election like i'm
not sure because i guess a lot of this
is unprecedented i'm not a
constitutional expert so the more they
keep doubling down on this stupidity
and agitating things and escalating the
situation
doesn't affect us we're just parked in
parking spots
uh and on the street but they're just
shooting themselves in the foot but like
i said in the very beginning um you know
extremists always double down on one
strategy they don't have they don't seem
to have
the fortitude and the observing ego to
look at things from the other
perspective and say okay well you know
how can we maneuver around this and get
other people on our side and negotiate
like it's it's quite shocking that
somebody who was elected with something
like 19 to the canadian citizenry
actually voted for justin trudeau
uh are sitting there on their high horse
like we're in command like no no you're
not
80 of the people want nothing to do with
you
and it's your job to come to the table
and talk to us and listen if he does
he will there shouldn't be much of a
conversation it's just
dude end the mandates and get rid of
this passport app that's it this is
pretty simple stuff like the solution
that peter paulier said it's staring him
right in the face
it's so easy and then they can claim
victory and they can say you know our
policies
saved millions of people and but now is
the time to go back and
we didn't really want to do it and
unfortunately but it was the best thing
for the country and spin it however they
want that's fine we know they're going
to do that some people will believe them
some people won't who cares we just get
back to what we should but they're just
holding on to this and it's just crazy
it makes no sense
okay wow
eddie i agree that this is absurd i'm
surprised actually i thought that
i thought sometime last week there would
be a roll out of well
country uh provinces around started
dropping their mandates right like
alberta said they were going to drop it
even ontario said things would go back
to normal eventually
and so i'm surprised that at a federal
level
they're not just looking at all the
provinces and all the people
or all the countries around the world oh
i know
like yeah or the rest of the world
basically
give or take australia australia has
still been iffy
and remember they said you know the
winter that's the most dangerous and
darkest time for covet okay well we're
now three weeks into this
uh we've had tens of thousands of people
here hugging partying together dancing
from all from various provinces in
canada
and i was in the hospital getting my uh
my leg reconstructed for surgery a
couple of days ago
and i didn't see saint elmo's fire and
you know
masses of bodies being rolled into the
icu and i spoke to the people there and
they said yeah we're worried we don't
want to have any you know massive uh
outbreaks in icu and i said how are
things now they said oh yeah it's quiet
okay
so
if it's not happening now then we all
know that this policy is the wrong
policy and it needs to be abandoned and
that's probably why the rest of the
world is doing so
okay
wow is there anything else you want to
tell people and is there anywhere people
could go to support you guys even though
those initiatives keep getting shut down
um yeah so
they can go to my twitter which is bj
dictor
uh d and so it's spelled b j d i c h c e
r
then go to tamara's twitter uh which is
tamara under and tamara underscore mvc
it's very important the reason we've
been focusing on our personal
uh platforms is because we've also had
to
navigate censorship online right
there is yeah that's it there's a um
there is
dave rubin is setting up
freedomconvoy.locals.com
so that's the next thing that's going to
be set up where you'll find information
be able to donate and whatever
uh the give send go is still there so
you'll be able to donate
uh the tally coin drive i think there's
another one now set up in bitcoin the
initial one was
uh put on hold since the announcement
from the canadian government but now
there's another group of people
that set up uh tally coin so if you just
go to freedom convoy or canadian
truckers you'll find
something again we're not so centralized
because of censorship
uh those three things but basically
monitor our oh and quicken report is
another uh podcast
it's another twitter account
that works with us and tom is one of our
team and one of the accounts that we
administer
if you keep an eye on those and myself
on getter same bj dictor you'll get all
the updates you need we'll post links
you'll get a sense of where we're at and
uh we're randomly posting you know links
to support if you want to send money on
gifts and go and all that sort of stuff
and we keep
getting everybody up to date with what's
going on that's really the best way
again oh and there is a freedom convoy
canada.com website
which again is being hacked or hacked
ddos attacks
and all that sort of stuff so when it's
up it's up when it's not it's not
um
and to everybody who's listening that i
just want to let you know this is not
about left or right you know i'm i'm not
a hardened
uh right wing person you know i like the
i like the variation of the scott adams
uh approach which is you know for me
personally and i think this explains a
lot of us
we like the goals of the left we like
the systems of the right
and we like the freedom of libertarians
and somewhere
yeah and somewhere between all of that
that's where we all fit and that's why
we have people
across the political spectrum like i did
an interview last week with this girl
she's an independent journalist because
i've been trying to do a lot of
independent
journalists
and she said to me
i used to be a separatist
until two weeks ago i bought my first
canadian flag because i've never been so
proud
i hate it almost puts a tear in your
make me cry yeah
so this is all about having our voices
heard
it's peaceful it's about love
unity
and restoring our basic freedoms to
choose to do what we want in terms of
bodily autonomy
we understand people are
afraid of the virus people should be
free
to protect themselves and quarantine at
their will and do whatever they want
but
the government has gone a little bit out
of control
in terms of how they can regulate our
lives
and like where does it end am i not
going to be able to ride motorcycles
anymore am i not going to be able to eat
fast food anymore
like that's where we're going with this
so
it's inclusive of everybody we have you
know for those who care
about racial diversity i don't really
care i care about individuals
but we do have people from various
communities from all over the world like
i mentioned the sikh community has been
a huge help in feeding people
because there are a lot of them in
trucking
and uh yeah we
the example of the quebecois
faction and the albertan faction
everybody coming together
like this is i think it's not attributed
to us it's attributed to everybody who
got involved
this is the
thirst for canadian unity that our
country has always needed
and i think we finally got there we just
need to get our politicians
to realize that's what's happened
okay well thank you very much for coming
on
[Music]
you